au delà des apparences c'est le sujet
d'aujourd'hui
je suis venu vous parler de
l'intelligence artificielle du savoir
humain du savoir machine qui se cache
derrière
l'intelligence artificielle ou ce qu'on
appelle de nos jours l'intelligence
artificielle
si on pense à l'intelligence
artificielle on a des différends images
depuis mon plus jeune enfance j'étais
entouré par le savoir pour le mans
famille ma soeur à l'âge de 4 ans et
l'arrivée à lire pas plus de cinq livres
elle a fait la grève et moi je les
accompagnais par pure mesure de
solidarité
mon père à l'enfant prodige comme elle
il faisait la recherche et maîtrisez
plus de cette langue oubliée non de mari
chercheur en ce qu'on appelle
intelligence artificielle
on a travaillé ensemble pendant plus de
15 ans moi-même chercheuse en ce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence à 10 cibles
son père un bon mari
philosophe quand vous voyez le savoir ça
m'a entouré dans ses différentes formes
ainsi différentes perspectives pendant
toute ma vie il y a je vais revenir sur
mon premier slide
il y a quinze ans quand j'étais
étudiante et que j'ai commencé ce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence artificielle pour
la segmentation des images pour la
chirurgie en temps réel j'apprends la
nouvelle j'ai un cancer
alors ma question il vient normalement
quelles sont les perspectives on me dit
statistiquement parlant vous avez 50 %
de réussite chances de réussite
alors je me demande je me demande si ou
le miracle de l'intelligence
artificielle
les experts y sont nombreux le savoir il
est là
les algorithmes de ce grappin des gens
satisfaits les sont présents depuis plus
de cinquante années
alors pourquoi se savoir il n'est pas
accessible ça on va le savoir à la fin
de ma présentation
mais voyons voir qu'est ce que nous on
comprend de savoir quelle est notre
vision de l'intelligence artificielle
qu'on vous l'avez déjà vu parce que
passer l'honneur d'avancis en 1495 il a
déjà créé une ressemblance et l'être
humain un chevalier mécanique convoyer
il a des articulations
il peut reproduire le mouvement d'un
être humain mais c'est pas le seul si on
y va un peu plus loin dans la créativité
les à automates de musique c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau
ici vous avez une représentation des
musiciens al jazairi mais le musée
d'instruments de musique de bruxelles
il a beaucoup d'autres exemples et ça
c'est toujours la automatisation on y va
un peu plus long on veut voir
l'intelligence derrière la
automatisation alors on voit apparaître
des automates joueur d'échecs des
karakuri qui sert du thé pour les
karakuri le geste il est toujours
mécanique vous fais le
retrouvez dans le musée de tokyo nahshon
sens musique ils sont là depuis le 19e
siècle
toujours à automatismes toujours répété
en mouvement et je vous ai parlé de ce
qui est là automatisé à l'automatisation
de l'intelligence les premiers joueurs
d'échecs automatisés là vous avez la
représentation du turc mécanique qu'on
vous le voyez c'était l'illusion de la
profondeur de la meubler qui nous
donnaient qui nous donnait cette
illusion
c'était l'homme qui était caché dans la
machine qui gèle échec qui manipulait la
marionnette et nous donne l illusion de
l'intelligence
une telle chance qui est semblable à
l'intelligence humaine et bien sûr que
le temps il a passé on est passé à
automates
on est passé au système qu'ils sont
capables de jouer à l'échec
ici vous avez l'exemple de alpha go qui
est développé par google dit mind et qui
a réussi
vang en face de lycée 12 pour le jeu de
go on a dit pub bluecar est aussi vendre
aussi pour les chèques beaucoup faisant
avant ici on à 2016 donc on se dit on
est quand même assez loin dans cette
automatisation on est capable de faire
des stratégies en utilisant le numérique
en se basant sur des nombres on fait ce
qu'on appelle number one thing
on est capable de manipuler ces nombres
et tirer les conclusions
rien de nouveau mais accrochons-nous de
nos jours approchons nous de savoir qui
se cache derrière cette intelligence
comment on définit ce savoir
trop long une chaise j'ai eu une
approche on l'a quand on veut définir
une notion asseyons nous ayons une
expérience on le définit par sa
structure ses quatre pieds sont assises
son dossier
le matériel qui la composent tissu métal
et l'expérience qu'on a avec le façon
dont nos sens ils peuvent le percevoir
si on le monde rio chaise à un enfant il
arrive le comprendre il à la notion il
va essayer de sentir
il va avoir l'expérience il a compris
trop longue de savoir machine on le
montre 750 images de chaises à
l'ordinateur
sept cent cinquante chaises formes
différentes structures différentes et à
chaque fois quand on lui montre une
image on associe l'étiquette chaise
simplement l'étiquette après ces
apprentissages
l'orateur il est capable de reconnaître
avec une certaine probabilité dans une
image une chaise pas dans le monde réel
dans une image d'azur et présentations
bi dimensionnel si on prend les mêmes
750 images et on le montre à l'enfant il
sera plus bouleversé qu'aux autres il ya
trop d'informations il a compris
pourquoi il a besoin de voir encore 750
images il a compris la notion allons
plus loin dans le savoir le rôle du
savoir donne un poisson à un homme il
mangera pendant une journée
un signe lui le péché dans lui le filet
il mangera pendant toute sa vie le filet
c'est aussi essentiel qu'elles notre
filet pour l'apprentissage
les premiers apprentissages on les a eus
par voie orale
viva voce on avait les grecs les romains
qui allaient dans l'agora
on avait les sages expliqué émotions et
on avait les autres qui les suivaient
qui apprenait ce qu'on appelle de nos
jours les ihm france avec tous les
moyens qui nous permettent de garder une
trace de cette savoir bambou papyrus
table ainsi re table en argile le savoir
il est devenu accessible à tout le monde
on a eu l'éducation nationale qui
moyennant le papier avec charlemagne par
exemple en france qui a pu prendre
existence même en pays si petit que
luxembourg à echternach on l'a investi
pour les premières livres bien sûr là
vous voyez le symbole de luxembourg au
milieu en bas le langage il était
toujours et présenté d'une manière
différente on le lisait de gauche à
droite de droite à gauche on le lisait
sur la verticale comme aux gammes en
irlande
mais ce qui reste c'est le caractère
linéaire
céline r on peut le percevoir comme ça
comment la machine elle comprend les
notions le nouveau savoir qui différent
du savoir humain pour les machines
il vient sous la forme d information
structurée avec des corrélations la
notion par exemple de d'avancis ça
représente un noeud dans un graphe ont
fait les corrélations part
progress perspective ce qui crée les
corrélations maintenant ses développeurs
ces analystes ont créé la relation en
disant d'avancis lac raymond la lys et
ont créé tout un univers autour mais ça
c'est juste une perspective si la
perspective du développeur c'est la
perspective qu'il a mis on voit pas le
chevalier mécanique ici on est coupé de
cette partie de la réalité parce que la
perspective c'est l'univers de
connaissances que le développeur qui
n'est pas forcément spécialistes dans
tous les domaines qui n'est pas en
mission
l'ami qu'est ce que ça change
fondamentalement c'est façon d'organiser
les connaissances ils sont accessibles
très peu sous forme d'un cycle au pdi
sous forme d'explication dans le domaine
un domaine où les moteurs de recherche
quelques acteurs économiques à part ça
tout est créé par les développeurs
les vrais un cyclo pdi sont créés par
les experts du domaine en disant comme
support le papier on l'a eue l'académie
on l'a eue le chercheur qui se sont mis
d'accord qu'on est arrivé à un consensus
mais non quand on crée les un cycle au p
10 ceux qui ont une valeur de
connaissances ont mis plusieurs experts
du domaine plusieurs perspectives
mais ce qu'on fait ça vraiment où est ce
qu'on laisse ça juste pour les
développeurs un grand effort que nous
tous homme d'affaires basque
intelligence artificielle ce moyen de
communication de l'information nous
concerne tous c'est se préparer pour ce
nouveau type de savoir préparer le
savoir pour la machine
la capacité de calcul est là
les algorithmes ils sont là depuis les
années 50 moment à l'avant on a tous les
moyens ce qu'il nous manque c'est une
information qui a de la valeur
une information qui est structuré qui
est corrélé que la machine peut utiliser
pour donner une valeur économique pour
donner une valeur
ce qu'on peut faire pour le savoir de
l'homme c'est le renforcer et on a trois
actions semble que tout le monde peut
faire c'est créer de nouvelles
compétences
ces nouvelles compétences et comment
naviguer ces graphes de connaissances
comme les journalistes on doit avoir
trois sources au moins pour avoir au
moins trois perspectives sur cette
information
sinon on les bornes et dans notre
perspective
deuxièmement il faut créer et contrôler
des encyclopédies le savoir pour
l'intelligence artificielle pour la
machine domaine par domaine et ça vient
avec deux piliers le premier pilier
c'est le plier technologique ceux qui
vont créer les algorithmes ce qu'ils
vont créer l'outil le deuxièmement il
vient du savoir métiers du maçon à
l'artisan à l'économiste aux financiers
chacun ona à savoir à savoir métier
qu'on l'a formé par l'éducation par
l'expérience chacun ont peu contribué à
ça le troisième n'oubliez pas d'utiliser
les différentes perspectives
pourquoi cette différentes perspectives
sont si importantes chacun on a nos
normes
on a notre parti les tic
chacun d'entre nous il se définit par
son parcours par sa culture
les normes d'éthique sont pas universels
mais d'éthique on peut passer à normes
standards iront peut renforcer sa dans
des cycles au pdi de savoir qu'ils sont
consensus un compromis en compromis
qu'on trouve et qui peut nous servir
d'une manière lucrative l'intelligence
artificielle ce qu'on appelle de nos
jours intelligence artificielle ça nous
concerne tous
si on n'agit pas maintenant quand j'ai
déjà
mentionnez il y a quelque peu acteurs
économiques qui ont ces encyclopédie il
y à quelques moteurs de recherche qui on
sait ainsi flopée dit la technologie
elle a évolué on va dire que
l'avancement ramené par l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
arrêter parce que c'est un accès à
l'information
c'est comme le papier il nous donne un
accès à l'information
mais pour le mettre en oeuvre on a
besoin de s'investir créer de nouvelles
compétences
les nouvelles compétences qui nous
permettent de naviguer l'information qui
nous permettent de ne pas s'investir
seul mandat les métiers qui sont liées
aux mathématiques au physique mais
comprendre qu'on a tous notre rôle mais
qu'il faut toujours bien s'entourer
créé le bon mélange de compétences pour
donner une valeur ajoutée comme anton
200 experts il dit il faut voir le monde
par les yeux d'un autre de cendres
merci
[Applaudissements]